anyway let's get started with what's
going on in Asia business right now so
let's look at the size of the world
economy about a hundred twenty trillion
dollars was the gross domestic product
for the entire world in if you calculate
it at purchase power parity and use
current international dollars so in the
top five countries three of them are
Asian right
China is considerably larger than the
u.s. now and India is also in the top
five Japan is also in the top five and a
lot of people are surprised to find out
that Indonesia is in the top ten
there are also on the right-hand side
ten other Asia economies that are in the
top 50 biggest economies in the world
now that alone means that there's some
very active markets in Asia but I think
the real interest in Asia comes from how
countries got there so if you look
historically at the growth and gross
domestic product there is China right
so you see Japan and Germany are very
nice stable low growth countries you see
India coming up
noticeably really India's growth rate
almost tracks the united states one
thing I want you to notice if you
compare the amounts back in 2003 to the
estimated amounts in 2017 2018 you're
seeing more than a 2x growth in most of
these countries you can't say that for a
Japan you can't say it for Germany but
for most of these countries you're
seeing greater than a doubling of the
size of the national economy in those 15
years that's a lot of new money to spend
and this is what business people get
interested in
if you look at the so-called Tigers
these are the places that used to be the
jumping-off points to China you see
South Korea growing quite fast
you see Taiwan growing quite well and
you see Singapore and Hong Kong really
close to each other a slight bit of
divergence later but even Singapore in
Hong Kong at their slower growth rates
are more than double their size 15 years
ago Southeast Asia yeah this is why
Indonesia is a country that we really
should pay a lot more attention to
people have missed Indonesia and the
growth rate for Indonesia it's almost
three times as big as it was 15 years
ago and the other economies are also
keeping above that 2x growth rate over
the last 15 years so the big picture
what's going on recently first of all I
think you have to say that Asia is
discovering itself or developing its own
ecosystem for growth the United States
is kind of letting itself be pushed over
to the side
and one factor is that what's happened
as the increase in wealth in Asia has
come a lot of that is coming from the
rise of a middle class and so what used
to be famous about Asia business is that
it was the world supply chain you would
have materials extracted in Australia
and Indonesia they would be put together
into parts in Japan and in Korea they
would be packaged and put into systems
in Malaysia and then these things would
be put together in China and sold on the
world markets now they're sold in Asia
markets and that's the biggest change I
think retail spending in Asia is growing
faster than GDP growth in every country
in Asia except for Japan
and this is still the case even though
the general GDP growth in China has
slowed from about nine or ten percent
down to about six and a half percent
consumer debt okay the more people spend
the more they want money to spend so
consumer debt is increasing you see this
in the graph here notice the sudden
sharp rise in China steady rise in South
Korea a rise in Malaysia and quite a
rise in Thailand and this is both good
and bad right the more consumer debt
there is probably trade balances would
naturally become lower with the United
States unless the United States is
accumulating even more debt I mean
that's one problem but a lot of the Asia
consumer debt is short-term that's not
fixed rate like a fixed mortgage so it's
dangerous stuff people could get to the
point where they can't pay back their
debt quite easily
even though mortgage debt has increased
as a percentage of household income the
second factor is that there's the
self-awareness of Asia as a unit that's
kind of maybe the wrong word to use but
this business of the trans-pacific
partnership after the u.s. pulled out at
the beginning of 2017 the other 11
countries decided to go on and do it
without the United States they signed
the agreement a few weeks ago and it's
now in the process of being ratified by
the different countries
now the participants are not just Asian
countries but they're definitely led by
Japan and to a certain extent Australia
and one of the important points about
TPP is that there is a lot of things in
this 3,000 page agreement that is not in
a traditional trade agreement most
traditional trade agreements are about
you know tariffs and the number of
oranges you can send into a country and
that kind of thing this has a lot about
data privacy
a lot about data governance a lot about
e-commerce that is really forward
looking for a trade agreement and they
suspended a few of the provisions the
new agreement is basically nine pages
long and it says we incorporate the
three thousand page agreement by
reference with the following exceptions
and there are 22 exceptions most of
which were things that big American
companies were arguing for so they have
been suspended not abolished so the way
is open to the u.s. to get back into it
if we want to don't hold your breath
more than even this though investment
inside Asia is really huge
so you're seeing a lot more investments
inside Asia by Asian investors not by
Silicon Valley investors you're starting
to see unicorns in Asia you're starting
to see more mergers and acquisitions as
exits in Asia this is actually
co-occurring with the rise of high net
worth individuals in Asia so for a long
time
Asia really missed having angel
investors the potentials there now the
bulk the plurality of high wealth
individuals in the world people who have
more than a million dollars of
investable assets not including their
own are in asia-pacific so notice how
this block has grown over the last eight
years six years according to this it
only goes to 2016 but so far it still
feels like a Darth of angel investors
okay well we'll keep we'll come back to
that in a little bit the other thing
that you have to say about Asia becoming
its own ecosystem for growth is that
Asia consumers and companies are both
very
aware of what we would call societal
problems and they're not just taking
them as problems or things that we're
stuck with they're turning them into
business opportunities so one of the
most famous ones is demographic change
talk about the aging society all across
Asia people get excited and they're
looking for business opportunities a lot
of the new digital technologies are
basically leapfrogging what we've done
in the West to make things accessible to
people who haven't been serviced before
so for example mobile banking about a
third of the people in Southeast Asia
did not even have a bank account and so
now mobile banking applications are a
really big deal all across Southeast
Asia interestingly enough the United
Nations Commission's this business and
sustainable development commission and
the business and sustainable development
commission has about 16 or 17 people on
its board of commissioners including
Jack Ma the CEO of Temasek and sunny for
Gaza who's the chair of the Financial
Group in Singapore so they came out with
a report last June that said that there
are about 12 trillion dollars of new
business opportunities that can be
achieved by the year 2030 that's a long
time in regard to addressing the 17
sustainable development goals that the
United Nations has put out so 12
trillion dollars and they say 5 trillion
will probably be achieved in Asia 40% so
out of that they see the biggest
opportunity for China 2.3 trillion a
trillion dollar opportunity in India in
developing Asia markets read Southeast
Asia 1 trillion and in the more develop
Asian markets you're still looking at
700 billion dollars that businesses are
probably going to find in addressing
environmental and social social
sustainability problems so of course the
shift of the digital economy is
definitely happening in Asia this is a
big deal as well
the second major factor going on in Asia
right now is that Southeast Asia is the
battleground for global influence first
of all on the government level we had
the TPP minus one so China has a much
bigger regional trade agreement called
the RCEP
the regional comprehensive economic
partnership and that would include all
of the ten countries in ASEAN plus the
six countries that do business with
ASEAN what an interesting way of
developing it of defining who's going to
be in the trade agreement ASEAN centric
the other thing that China is doing is
this huge one belt one road initiative
now called the belt and road initiative
and it's really an infrastructure
investment project that started out with
the countries that were historically in
the Silk Road between China and Europe
but now is extended to over 68 countries
all over the place but certainly
Southeast Asia is in the center of a lot
of what's going on they built their own
Bank to fund a lot of this China has a
26 percent stake in it and currently
China has put over 150 billion dollars
into one belt one road projects and the
total investment by all parties because
usually this is a subsidy from China
that must be matched by local funding by
the local government or by local
industry will reach about four trillion
dollars so this is a lot of money but
the problem is
other governments might end up only
China a lot of money this has happened
in Sri Lanka Sri Lanka got some money to
develop their ports from China they
couldn't pay back the loans and so now
China has a ninety nine you're more or
less free lease to use the ports in Sri
Lanka for military or civilian purposes
so this is definitely about influence
and Southeast Asia is kind of in the
center of it look at the investments
that the big companies are making so
Alibaba made a 1 billion dollar
investment in an Indonesian ecommerce
company in August last year they
increase their total investment in
lazada which is a competitor to
tokopedia to four billion dollars
they're in talks to acquire an
e-commerce firm in Malaysia that had
already been receiving money from a
South Korean investor SK Planet and the
Malaysian telecom company oxy otta so
not just Alibaba Tencent is definitely
in the game they invested in the
ride-sharing service go Jack which is a
competitor to uber in Indonesia and they
had also backed C limited which does
online games before C went public on the
New York Stock Exchange last year so
they probably made good on their
investment although right now C is
trading below its IPO price $0.10
outspent
the other famous Internet companies in
China Alibaba and Baidu in mergers and
acquisitions over the last six years
spending sixty two point five billion
dollars a lot of this is going down into
Southeast Asia and you see the fights
going on not just on the investment
front so Amazon has started its prime
delivery service in Singapore last
summer and complete Prime
ship is available in Singapore since
November and this is competing against
largely other Southeast Asia and Asia
backed competitors lazada had come up
with its own version of Prime membership
before that and they were doing this and
partner with uber and in partner with
Netflix Expedia has made 350 million
dollar investment in travel oka along
with Sequoia the US version of the firm
and JD comm which is a Chinese
e-commerce firm and then the latest news
kind of the last couple of months is
that uber is having to sell its
Southeast Asia business to the biggest
ride-hailing company in Southeast Asia
grab-grab claimed at the time I put this
together to be in 36 Southeast Asian
cities and have 1.1 million drivers
latest number I heard is 90 cities and 5
million drivers so this is not good for
grab because now Singapore is
investigating this as a possible
non-competitive activity that was just
in the news today but probably
something's going to happen and notice
that grab was being backed by the
company that basically ran Ober out of
China BD shushing shushing sorry so this
kind of battle for influence is really
happening a lot on Southeast Asian
territory
the third big thing going on in Asia
business right now has to do with
economic development and this really
pulls back to an 80 thousand foot level
maybe the view from orbit about what
goes on when a company industrialize
--is and becomes an advanced economy the
so called factor driven economies if you
think developing economies that's fine
basically it's at this stage where you
see a gold rush of growth because there
is no or
industrial base at the beginning of this
period and so creating the industrial
base is a huge opportunity the
government at this kind of stage of
growth is really doing basic commercial
laws and kind of really trying to
establish the rules for having business
the next phase that the World Economic
Forum calls efficiency driven is when a
company a country has a few companies
that really become global players
they're they're becoming big
multinational companies they are able to
get the best labor because they offer
the best kind of conditions parents want
their children to go to work for these
prestigious companies this happened to
Japan in the 1960s it happened to Korea
in the 1980s it's happening in China
right now and the things that make
economies strong at this stage are
efficiency the ability to scale up the
ability to do things really really well
like precision manufacturing it's at
this stage that governments start to pay
attention to intellectual property and
then once you get up to about thirty
five thousand dollars a year
gross domestic product per person all
calculations that purchase power parity
where do you get your next growth the
big companies have already globalized so
where has continued growth coming from
innovation and the World Economic Forum
basically looks at this it's at this
stage where fresh new ideas and
out-of-the-box thinking become keys to
growth that the big companies don't see
this is why the big companies start to
look at startup companies in this stage
anyway this kind of a situation in Asia
is having the following kind of outcomes
Japan and South Korea are really in the
innovation driven stage but not
comfortable there yet they are
still having trouble with encouraging
entrepreneurship the big firms basically
control the b2b business sectors and
they are not doing a really good job
with open innovation there's this is a
complicated situation but we'll talk a
little bit more about it but in both
Japan and in South Korea in the last two
or three years you're seeing a huge
explosion in entrepreneurial activity
it's really noticeably different when
you go to Japan now even than three or
four years ago in China I've seen one
published article in March last year
that worried about the middle income
trap I've been talking about the
possibility of a middle income trap in
China for a couple of years now and sure
enough the problem is that the big
companies become so prestigious they
siphon off a lot of the good labor from
the in the labor market that would
otherwise go into start-up companies not
necessarily as entrepreneurs but as
workers and startup companies also in
China there's a lot of government
research funding that's going to
universities and national research
institutes but the famous companies in
China didn't have a whole lot to do with
that Baidu Alibaba $0.10 may be always
an exception but most of the companies
that have really become the global
companies in China were private sector
companies that didn't have particularly
close connections with any of the
universities so it's questionable as to
what kind of return the government's
really getting from its research funding
and it's also dangerous because one of
the things that countries tend to do at
the middle level this efficiency driven
level is the government start to pick
the winners and governments can pick
winners for infrastructure development a
lot easier than they can pick winners
for consumer driven growth
government somehow don't think like
consumers you see that you saw this in
Japan with the national projects and the
80s and 90s that didn't really turn into
anything you're seeing it now with Korea
kind of its continuing frustration with
the Chabal and so will it be a trap in
China right now we don't know it is
early to see there are good things for
and they're good things against let's
take a look at what's happening with the
the kind of actual participation and
entrepreneurship any questions or
comments about what I've said so far you
want to take a minute and talk about
this because we're about to get into
another set of data here go ahead yes
Asia not Sanford not near you you can
always find will I'll put up the slides
within a day or two and hopefully the
video will be up within a few days too
so I think that the system had to reach
a certain amount of torque before it
broke and I think that we're really
seeing more students more people who are
not satisfied with what used to be the
best way to fame and fortune which was
go to work for a big company you're
seeing more fluidity you're seeing young
people who will go to work for a big
company for a few years and then quit so
I think that it is it does have a
relationship to the government and the
media positive hammering about how
important entrepreneurship is for the
country so that has had an impact but I
think that more than that the system was
just ready to change and it was going to
change sometime
finally it's starting to change good
question
other questions before we go go ahead
mark investment in Asia is a grind in
Japan I heard um I'm still VCS don't
have a capability to look into that know
what is that going to good businesses
and so that's why you know many money is
there but there are no wedding best yeah
okay
we'll come back to this house I've got
more slides obesity as I go along good
question
trends in Asia have to do with the
percentage of people from each Asian
country I want you to us or Western
world for higher education wow what a
great question I'm not sure I think that
certainly the success of Silicon Valley
has been attractive to the rest of the
world okay but that's media we have had
a lot of people coming here from China
for years now right and so I think that
some of them are going back and doing
interesting things so Bobby will Bobbie
Lee who was BTCC CEO is coming back at
the end of the month he'll talk about
this I think that you have just a
general favorable view about
entrepreneurship that is catching hold
and this is exactly where we're going
with this part of the talk okay so
today's lecture I want to first
introduce where I'm getting a lot of my
data so there is this thing called the
Global Entrepreneurship monitor
consortium that's run by Babson College
and there are three other major partners
in this but there are thousands of
people involved in data collection for
this because they survey almost 150 to
200 thousand people a year they will not
put data down for a country unless they
have gotten good surveys from a sample
of at least 2,000 people for a country
so it's a big survey
it's done every year the first one they
did was 1999 and I'm only picking the
parts of it that I trust so there are
other things in this that are a little
bit more controversial but what I'm
looking at are the actual participant
the adult population survey that they're
doing to find out how many people are
involved in entrepreneurial activities
and what are the attitudes by people in
the population if they're not involved
in entrepreneurial activities so their
website is where you can get all this
data I pull the data in a different way
than they do because there is a lot of
cultural difference between countries
and if people say they're afraid of
failure maybe that's a culturally
acceptable answer in some countries and
it's a less positive answer in other
countries right we don't like to admit
being afraid of failure here but if
you're in Asia maybe you think that
you're being really arrogant if you're
not afraid of failure so there's a lot
of cultural difference but if you look
over time at the same country then you
can see a lot of changes that may be
meaningful so at the core of what I'm
interested in is what they call total
early stage entrepreneurial activity the
tea rate and this is people who are
either setting up a new business or
they're running a new business that has
paid salaries for less than three and a
half years and that's better than stage
of funding or anything else once a
company starts to pay salaries it kind
of is on the growth as a to stability as
a startup company we hope so this total
early-stage entrepreneurial activity is
people in this part of the process
the general trend that they published is
that the tea rate decreases as countries
go through this process of economic
growth so the far left over here these
are factor driven economies efficiency
driven economies and innovation driven
economies so that's their average for 54
countries it's interesting that when you
divide up men and women you see
different kinds of profiles but one
thing that's really important is that
the women who are involved in
entrepreneurship in the middle stage the
efficiency driven stage by far are doing
so because they felt like they had no
choice they're an entrepreneur out of
necessity not because they're trying to
see some particular opportunity in
contrast the men have a relatively you
know kind of stable attitude toward
necessity versus opportunity at the the
first two stages in their their
responses to the survey Asian economies
I don't have this are much more driven
by opportunity than by necessity but
having said that let's take a look at
the US will take the US as a baseline so
this is the tea rate in the United
States over the last 15 years so okay
after the 2008 financial crisis people
formed fewer companies now it's
interesting there was a lot of people
interested in entrepreneurship at this
time but maybe there was no money
available right was those practically no
VC investing going on in 2009 and 2010
so you did see a drop there but ever
since 2011 it's so relatively stable you
get some year-to-year variation now
let's see how the US fits into the big
five these are the top five economies in
the world so
here's the us the gray line and you see
this incredible variation year to year
in China and also in Indonesia right not
the top five top ten pardon me the Asian
countries their Japan is very flat
doesn't grow doesn't doesn't change a
lot maybe over the long term you see a
slight amount of growth but it's really
the year-to-year variation in China and
in Indonesia that are striking probably
this indicates the economies in the
state of change what you get one year is
very different from what you get the
next year because of things like news
items and availability of money it's
public programs that kind of thing if
you look at the Tigers all of the Tigers
have lower T rates than the United
States does not a lot lower but lower
and what you see is of real stability in
Taiwan right the gaps for countries are
years in which they didn't take any data
from that country and yet you also see
what appeared to be increases in
Singapore and Hong Kong and South Korea
especially this noticeable jump between
2016 and 2017 I have a suspicion that if
you could go back to 2001 2002 you would
see South Korea having much more active
entrepreneurship and then the government
fell and the chat ball kind of took over
the economy again so it depressed things
for a while in Southeast Asia you get a
lot of volatility variability in
Thailand up at the top very high level
of high tea rate
Malaysia is a remarkably low T rate
until the last year now
if there was some sort of a problem in
how they conducted their survey that
might be an explanation but it could
also have to do with external factors
remember Thailand has had who the
military took over the government there
have been major floods one or two years
so you may be seeing external factors
that are causing this kind of wide
year-to-year variation but they all have
higher T rates than the US okay this is
a beginning I think that if you talk
about the amazing growth in GDP across
Asia it's sort of surprising that the T
rates not going down more how come it's
not tracking what though
Global Entrepreneurship monitor said was
there 54 country average of drop and T
rate as countries become more advanced
the China decline may be related to the
general slowdown of the economy but
there's an awful lot more venture
capital money in China to kind of offset
that oh I think you have to look at the
attitudes toward entrepreneurship by
people who are not doing
entrepreneurship so here's what we're
going to look at this is the u.s.
profile in four areas that people asked
here's the tea rate these are people who
are actually involved in
entrepreneurship of the people who are
not involved in tea activities 63 and a
half percent of working-age adults in
the United States so saw good
opportunities around them for starting a
business that's we'll see that's a very
high percentage but lots of
opportunities for entrepreneurs
fifty-four percent of working-age adults
in the u.s. felt that they have the
ability to start a company 33 percent of
the working age adults in the u.s. said
that constraints from start they felt
constrained from starting a business due
to fear of failure and the last one is
intention to start a company 14 and a
half percent of working-age adults in
the u.s. said that they intend to start
a business within the next three years
so of course if you don't have a higher
intention rate than a tea rate that's
kind of something's really strange
they're right you should you would
expect more people to intend to start a
business that are actually rent the
starting and running one now if you
compare how these attitudes in the
United States developed over the last 15
years the big change is in perception of
opportunities Wow the press has really
been effective here right people see
opportunities for entrepreneurs all
around them the perceived capabilities
in the United States is actually quite
stable we're a very confident people I
can't this is remarkable actually the
fear of failure has gone up some but not
a whole lot and actually compared to
Asia it's lower than just about
everywhere we will see and the tea rate
and the intentional rate is pretty close
to you know these two are really
tracking each other very closely so it's
interesting how close together those
lines are but it's basically a
relatively stable graph all right what
happens in China China is a very
interesting economy first of all there
was this huge bump in the tea rate and
also in positive attitudes toward
entrepreneurship in the year 2011 the
year that the government announced that
entrepreneurship was a strategic
national objective so this is you get
external factors there is a lot of
year-to-year variation I think that
overall you see an increase in the fear
of failure right the fear of failure is
the one that's gone up the moe
in that graph and you also see kind of
an ambivalent attitude toward the
opportunities for entrepreneurs
relatively strong right 35% now remember
it in the United States at 63% right so
that hasn't changed a whole lot the same
thing about capabilities haven't changed
a whole lot maybe a slight drop in
capabilities the entrepreneurial
intentions seem to have gone down quite
a bit but there's still a lot higher
than the actual tea rate so that
indicates that there will be a supply of
entrepreneurs that it's not going to
disappear anytime soon you would expect
the decline in tea right given the kind
of changes now there's other things that
you can do you can get a good job
somewhere else in South Korea what
you're noticing is considerably less
perception of opportunities until the
last two years the opportunities that
people saw for entrepreneurs floated
around 12% whereas in the United States
a 63% now right then has been going up
steadily but just in the last couple of
years there's a real nice bounce so
maybe this is part of what you were
asking about where that came from
is a good question I I'm guessing that
it really has to do with a positive
government attitude incentive programs
but also the press people really do pay
attention to the media in this kind of
thing you see a fear of failure that
looks high but actually that's about the
same rate as fear of failure in China so
it's not distinctively high you're
seeing a pretty big gap between
intention and actual tea rate especially
that gap has really hit here so
something very new so that a lot of
people are immediately
interested in entrepreneur
entrepreneurship but they haven't yet
started their companies if you go on to
Thailand you see a pattern in which the
perceived opportunities is higher than
China 49% in 2017 right
and it's been high relatively throughout
ever since ever since 2011 right you've
got this unfortunate gap here and it
really looked bad at this point when was
the coup I can't remember when that was
it was more recent right something may
have been going on in the country at
that point external factor but I would
also look at people's self-assessment of
their abilities but also a very high
fear of failure right the fear of
failure rate is pretty much steady the
same as it is in China higher than it is
in the United States but it's really the
entrepreneurial opportunities that seems
to be the distinctive difference the
actual rate of entrepreneurship tracked
very closely for some years but it's
really broadened the huge gap in the
last couple of years so maybe there will
be even more entrepreneurial activity in
Thailand before long and then yeah okay
you got to look at Japan Japan it looks
like the fear of failure is off the
chart
but it's only 8 or 9 percent above the
fear of failure rate in Southeast Asia
or in China it's really not that far
different it's just that everything else
is so low very few people see on to
opportunities for entrepreneurs in Japan
and you do have a low assessment of
one's ability to be an entrepreneur in
Japan so that kind of you know the
lowness and opportunities and then
perceived capabilities is probably much
more important than the fear of failure
that looks to be not that different to
other Asian countries
yeah so what about the ecosystems that
foster entrepreneurship those what I've
talked about are really people issues
right and people are one element of an
entrepreneurial ecosystem I think that
if you're talking about a startup
company you're talking about how a
combination of people and some idea and
some capital come together in a new way
a new combination is a good definition
of innovation and certainly if people in
capital and an idea come together in a
new company than you have
entrepreneurial innovation if you're
looking at the ecosystem for supporting
entrepreneurship you need different
kinds of things in those different
blocks at different stages of growth at
the beginning of course you need
founders but you also need people who
will be good advisors to a company the
first money that account that a company
gets is probably going to be from an
individual investor the kind of things
that you need in regard to ideas and
knowledge you do need access to new
ideas you need things like design
thinking you also need the perception of
access to market this is the perceived
opportunity thing right and on the
infrastructure side there are things
that you can have in a national
infrastructure that really help or
hinder startups from forming but notice
that the real issue for a startup
company to be successful is not so much
the entrepreneur it's this stage where
you need people who will go to work for
somebody else's startup company if you
can't get good people in a startup
company you cannot grow it you can't be
successful with it so you need that this
is where you see things like Lean
Startup principles and rapid prototyping
Investor Relations is a very important
kind of idea knowledge to have at this
stage
and this is a stage where VC money
really comes in not so much the first
funding for a company but really the
second funding our third funding and
then you have the exit stage there are
two ways that people two kinds of
opportunities that will allow the
investors and a company to sell their
stock if it's bought by another company
so M&A or if the company stock goes
public on a public exchange at this
stage you really need post exit
opportunities for the founders and the
employees if the founders try to stay at
their company all the time their
knowledge doesn't go to the next startup
company whereas a good serial
entrepreneur will take their knowledge
from one company to the next one so you
see that these kinds of things you need
different things at each stage in Asia
like everywhere else in the world
startup companies start with friends and
family money most Asian economies don't
have sufficient angel investors if you
look at those high-net-worth individuals
most of them in Asia are high net worth
because of real estate I saw a list of
the of the ten richest women in China
last week when I was preparing for this
seven of them are in real estate so you
know this is not you know angel
investing the venture capital
investments have grown in Asia we'll
talk about that next few slides there's
this flood of VC money in China and yet
they tend to be a little bit different
than the VCS are here they're much more
of a financial institution in Asia and
think less like the kind of serial
entrepreneur ish attitude that venture
capital investors do here the exit
patterns are quite different between
Asia and the US and I have slides for
all of this so if you look worldwide the
blue lines the United States
4,000 venture capital deals in 2012 5000
venture capital deals in 2017 but look
from 743 deals in Asia it went up to
2800 47 deals in Asia in 2017 the amount
of money raised went up in Asia from 5.2
million billion excuse me - almost as
much as the United States in 2017 that's
a huge amount of growth in venture
capital a lot of it is coming out of
China the venture capital in China a lot
of it is connected to government money
there's not only sovereign wealth funds
in China but a lot of incentives to the
financial institutions to create VC
funds in China there's quite a bit of
strategic corporate venture capital like
we saw with Alibaba and 10 cent doing
all of their investments and China is
the new home to the mega deals in the
last quarter of 2017 there were six
deals worth 1 billion dollars or more
and three of them happened in China so
this is this is big deal look at who's
the lead investors right an Indian
investor and I guess maybe you can say a
Japanese investor soft prank is is huge
now you've got Asia investment in more
of these right densa is a Japanese media
company and they're one of the investors
in Grail so the mega deal has really hit
China and so there's a lot of money the
exit pattern in the United States is
really about 10 percent of the exits or
less than 10 percent of the total
exits
buyouts merger and acquisition are by
IPO in the United States and the amount
of money raised is not that much but
look at the corresponding chart from
Asia a lot more IPOs in Asia but look
how little money is raised by IPOs in
Asia the IPOs are much smaller and this
is not the case in China okay
China is rather different from the other
countries in Asia in this regard but
even in China exit is still
predominantly by IPO less by M&A why is
this important it's important because
the big companies are not profiting from
open innovation like they are in the
United States if there are nine out of
ten exits happen by a big company
scooping up the startup company even
though that's often an ugly process it
means that the big company is seeing a
business opportunity someone else has
incubated and they think will be good
for them that pattern has not hit Asia
as much as it has in the United States
so in India the number of deals is down
quite a bit
drastically the amount of money is a lot
lower than it was in 2014-2015
but basically what you've got is more
money flowing into a few mega deals in
India so in other countries for example
in Japan so we had what 70 billion
dollars raised in Asia last year of
which 2 billion was from Japan the
world's fourth largest economy so two
and a half billion dollars went into
start-up companies in Japan in 2017 that
is an awful lot more than six years ago
right
almost right almost four times more than
it was six years ago
strategic corporate venture capital by
Japanese companies accounted for about
671 million dollars of the venture
capital investments in 2017 now this is
obviously not including things like soft
banks Vision Fund which itself is 93
billion dollars in size but strategic
corporate venture capital by Japanese
companies that want some sort of
partnership with a startup company as
well as to invest in it amounted to
quite a bit a lot more than in the
United States the United States average
is somewhere between 13% and 20% of all
deals venture capital deals will involve
corporate participation the average in
Asia is about 30% and Japan is even a
little higher than the Asia wide average
over half of Japanese corporate venture
capital with the companies outside Japan
so guess who's in Silicon Valley so
Panasonic ventures is now investing
along with scrum ventures here in the
valley there are quite a few Japanese
companies that are here in the valley
that are quite active in South Korea
also kind of sad 574 million dollars in
2017 and that was 30 percent less than
it was in 2016 so considering seventy
billion dollars in Asia you realize how
big the China percentage of all of this
investing is it is true that Singapore
by itself invested 1.2 billion dollars
in one hundred and twelve deals which is
not bad if you think it's only for a six
million person economy but Southeast
Asia venture capital funding is almost
all
sidered in singapore funds that invest
actively in Indonesia that invest
actively in Malaysia that invest
actively an Indian even in Dubai will be
based in Singapore so Southeast Asia is
still in the early stages
except for this small number of mega
deals right the the big go jaqen and
those kinds of deals so this is what
Ernst and Young said in their analysis
of venture capital funding that I
thought was really interesting venture
capital is growing around Oh fifteen or
twenty percent a year in the EU and in
Israel and in the United States and the
this is in terms of volume and this is
in terms of deal value whereas India and
China are much more aggressive and then
Southeast Asia is really way out there
growing at a very high rate because it's
growing growing from a very low base
okay the people flow in pattern the
people flow is really what we were
talking about with all of that data from
the Global Entrepreneurship monitor
right the the tea rate and the attitudes
toward entrepreneurship it's a fact that
you find out to rehearse everywhere the
real issue for Asia is the growth stage
it's still hard in Asia to get the best
people to come to work for a small
rapidly growing company that's not
prestigious it used to be easy in China
it's getting harder and harder and you
know Baidu write the b8e are draining
off the good workers in China now one of
the problems is that incentivization is
not well developed in most Asian
economies the people who do come to
school here know an awful lot more about
stock options when they go back and that
they're starting to negotiate with
people about jobs I think that may be
why a lot of them are founding their own
companies
there is this social stigma and the fear
of failure is talked about a lot in Asia
and it is higher than the United States
but as we saw in all those details
slides I really think that the
perception perception of lack of
opportunities is a much bigger factor in
whether people will go into into
entrepreneurship or not it's a rational
decision fear of failure doesn't sound
rational but if you don't see good
opportunities why should you bother
especially this is the case if the labor
market has a relative lack of mobility
lifetime employment has been a bad
tradition in Japan because if you quit
your company to go to work for a new
company you'll never go back whereas
that happens a lot here somebody quits
Google and starts a company they may be
hired back at Google or the company may
be bought by Google and they come back a
few years later so this is you know also
a problem at exit because too many of
the entrepreneurs in places like Japan
and Korea want to keep too much of their
stock and create a new family company
here we expect to exit I'll sell my
stock leave the money to my children and
start another venture so that kind of
attitude change is still evident in age
or attitude differences evident in Asia
I think that there's been a big focus on
commercialization inside universities
all across Asia innovation is the key
word right and what they're really
talking about is commercialization of
their research output there's not nearly
enough attention to the flow of business
knowledge to founders you'll get three
or four students from one PhD group in
some university in Asia starting a
company and there won't be a single
business person with business experience
in the group so that hasn't changed yet
mentoring has not yet developed like it
has here a lot of it has to do with the
sense of face if the mentor is so highly
respected you can't disagree with them
really right and one thing about
mentoring people here they may take your
advice but they may not I think that you
have less confrontational board
management kind of management investor
relations here or in Asia than you do
here and you know the Confucian version
of apprenticeship doesn't really lead to
a lot of discussion of the reasons for
failure why did you fail I didn't try
hard enough will typically be the answer
you get and so this sort of thing
doesn't really help for mentoring except
for China
I think startup companies have
traditionally had more difficulty
getting to market in Asia especially in
b2b areas and finally this failure of
open innovation systems the big
companies aren't helping the economy and
we need their money to flow into the
exits of startup companies for it really
to be successful so 0.1 Asia's ecosystem
for growth is moving along fine thank
you are we part of it maybe not the new
drivers of growth there's this
continuing structural change in China
there is a new middle class in Southeast
Asia people are really paying attention
to the social and environmental problems
that people have in Asia there's this
growth of the Asia investment community
where China is really moving into world
prominence as an investor in new
ventures Southeast Asia is a hotspot for
competition and what this means for us
is that if we're not careful we our big
companies won't be players in those
markets and this is kind of like the
automobile industry in the 1970
if you can't have global revenue you
can't keep up innovation enough to be
competitive so this is a real issue for
the United States we've got to be in
this competition we've got to be
fighting along with it the
Entrepreneurship ecosystems are growing
fast they're robust you can see this
kind of ecosystem in the participation
and entrepreneurship and the attitudes
toward entrepreneurship and there are
still some ecosystem weaknesses in Asia
finally what's the wild card trade war
what happens if we have one if we don't
have one I think the important thing is
if you're a company what do you do right
the emerging venture capital industry in
China and Southeast Asia is definitely a
big issue to watch but be careful will
it be too much influenced by government
strategy or general hype I've heard that
if you claim your company is built
around some AI technology your
evaluation in China is double what it is
if you're not is that hype it does kind
of look like 1998-1999 calm to me the
development of capacity for open
innovation by big companies is
proceeding and so I think that the big
companies aren't yet getting the value
it's a difficult organizational learning
challenge but they are learning they're
doing more than they used to be but this
is going to take more than one year to
develop so that's my presentation about
what's going on in entrepreneurship this
year in Asia it's one of the most
exciting kind of topics you can be
involved with we need to look at it we
need to be playing in these competition
games we really need to be there and you
know I'm looking forward to what our
guest speakers will say for the
of the series but I'm happy to open the
floor to questions now what do you have
go ahead we watch back with Steve Blank
last quarter and I thought it's very
inspiring to see how his Lean Startup
methodology can apply to the US market
but in the sense of an Asian market more
specifically in China how well do you
think the Lean Startup principles apply
to startups in China that's also a
really good question I think that it's
not only how they apply here versus
China it kind of depends on the business
one thing about innovation is no one
solution works all the time and you know
you can come up with a minimally
valuable minimally Viable Product and
get crowd response or market response as
quickly as possible if it's a consumer
based application how does that apply in
medical fields I don't really want to be
the you know guinea pig taking the
minimally Viable Product drug but you
know his his model is a great model and
it has had a huge impact in the United
States I think that in China it's likely
to be popular and I think it may be more
popular there than in other Asian
economies in many ways China is very
much like the US in terms of people
attitude we're just not as fast as China
now okay go ahead
what happened these days authority to
apprise Kappa applying Lean Startup
methodology to Japan is also a good
challenge Japan has a very robust early
adopter consumer market so games have
done really well in Japan you know other
kinds of things do really well in
consumer markets in Japan but again b2b
is not the play
- try Lean Startup too much in Japan
right
you'll you're beat up too much you
really have to have a good solution that
is ironclad maybe not all the bells and
whistles but I think that probably the
most important thing that I would say
about Lean Startup is like all
principles design thinking or whatever
they are wonderful ways of codifying a
particular approach a way to do things
but whenever you apply that to a
specific situation this is reality and
this has to take precedence you have to
always be willing to give in your
approach if it will get the right
results but you know that's why this is
hard this that's why you know that's why
innovation can't be cloned you know why
is it a continuing area of
competitiveness for a high income
economy
you can't standardize it if you could
standardize the way you start a company
and make it grow sure the law flow to
lower-cost economies we're going to be
out of that market - but innovation just
doesn't work that way
it's a combination of cleverness and
risk-taking that is different each time
but also a good question other go ahead
with trade word but I was wondering your
thoughts on national security especially
US China so okay I know this is a very
important topic and I think that
national security was used as a reason
behind the recent tariffs and that's
using an h-bomb to kill a rabbit okay
it's really not a good idea
and I personally don't think the tariffs
are a good idea I think that there has
been a lot of protectionism in various
economies China certainly protectionist
you look at the companies that you can't
get in China you can't see Facebook in
China right you can't see YouTube in
China that kind of thing has is not that
unusual in the history of the world it
was kind of that way in Japan 30 or 40
years ago and as China develops in order
to open up the playing field for
start-up companies in China they can't
be as protectionist right that's got to
change
but the United States really needs to
find ways to leverage its position in
the world community in order to have
more influence this is a huge battle for
influence going on not only in Southeast
Southeast Asia is a big market right 600
million people 30 40 % of world GDP is
in Southeast Asia and so we have to be
able to not try to do everything by
ourselves but really work with the
community to have the kind of influence
we need the national security issue is
also whenever you have dual use
technologies you have export controls
ITAR regulations that is a difficulty
for American companies that American
companies need to be prepared for but in
general when you have a regulatory
problem there's always a solution and so
I think that you know we've done pretty
well with dealing with highly regulated
areas but you know I certainly National
Securities an area and it's interesting
when you're talking about know-how you
can't keep other countries from getting
it so what you have to do is to be more
agile more nimble faster
and come up with better things yourself
one thing about the innovation economy
is you have to always be on the leading
edge beside so that's a good question a
difficult topic other questions go ahead
more to that evidence on the
productivity of these startups are these
early-stage companies because you know
the bigger picture is if growth is going
to be attributed to the future of
innovation love to hear your thoughts on
whether what you see in Asia is because
of its with what's been argued is it's a
competitive advantage you know better at
Auto you know spend on electronics or is
it how much a bit of the future DC is
going to be because they're innovative
and these early stage organizations are
leading the charge our activity you've
asked a hugely important theoretical
question what kind of evidence could
there be
so one kind of evidence I can think I
would be value at exit right so if you
go back and you look at the value at
exit of these companies you may see
something that is giving you some sort
of an indication of how much their
innovation has been valued I think that
people have tried you know looking at
high-value patents how many patents go
into international PCT patent
cooperation treaty that's an indirect
measurement at best and one of the
things is how do you measure
productivity and innovation companies
can't even measure the productivity of
their own research and development
people it's not the number of patents
you write a year it's not how many bugs
you find in the software code it's
really difficult and so you have to look
for these things I would look for exits
I would look for value at exit as an
indication and I think that when I'm
asked by a region to talk about
improving their regional innovation
system always look at what they're
strong at because what they're strong at
will be the jumping-off place for the
next thing
if you look back at the history of
Silicon Valley on the IT side we're
called Silicon Valley because of silicon
wafer manufacturing there's not a single
silicon wafer manufacturer left in
that's got its Factory in the valley
from that came the computer chip era
right with Intel from that came the
computer systems era with Sun
Microsystems from that came you know the
software era with Oracle and it just
keeps going on the Internet era the
e-commerce era right
and now the sharing economy really if
you look at what Tesla Motors does it's
building an IT system around a mobile
base and it's really the value of the
connectivity as much as the value of the
in the motor that is really worthwhile
so you know you always look at what
something's strong at as the next
jumping-off place where can you jump
from here but it's really hard to
measure yeah maybe one more question if
there are none we've got we should have
some refreshments outside and I'm happy
to stand around and get to know you a
little bit better thanks very much for
coming everybody and we will have a
session next week we'll talk to you more
about that soon
[Applause]
you